all right 80 milligrams of ketamine and
four comma eight I made a family that
should do the job
transliterating and doesn't happen very
often it's a last dessert for me and
really walk up to the cage now underbase
goal is the same three changes button
gets really a good aim this is the color
that we're going to put on and it's got
a VHF and satellite GPS satellite unit
is equipped with a drop off mechanism so
this collar will drop off in June 2018
by that time we would have established
where the animal is settled into a home
range and what has happened to the
animal
if it's half away can you start
stimulating him then it's not good we
wait till he sleeps deep enough and then
we go closer I'm just going to do all
the measurements and hideous body
temperature wait now he has injury he
just spoken in this if we look back at
ten years ago when you started I get the
think of animals would be shot in the
capture pitch in the last year only 0.3%
was killed so I think we've come a long
way in terms of changing perception and
working with landowners and farmers
looking at open
it reached our relief site the protected
area we'll be looking for a tree and we
can throw the rope over to open the
capture cage gate sire rope through the
gate and flow that rope over a tree and
then from the inside of the car pull it
open but everybody should be in the cars
now when we pull this open please
windows rolled up lipids are not like
cheetahs alliance that when you release
them I just run off liquid thing to come
back and attack you sometimes I take
this down we cannot reverse him a little
bit more if you release a animal into a
release site they must be fully awake of
these other predators in the area
very good
[Music]
all in the day's work
nothing that's what it's all about so
quiet doesn't cause any trouble
so we save these life and go one lipid
more on the planet